a president Donald Trump's daily
intelligence briefing was scheduled for
10:30 a.m. Eastern Time yesterday
Wednesday February 8th 21 minutes after
the scheduled start of that daily
intelligence briefing at 10:51 a.m.
Eastern Time Donald Trump moved on to
apparently more important parts of his
day going from the latest information to
keep us safe to tweeting about his
daughter Ivanka's business affairs with
Nordstrom's take a look at this tweet
that Donald Trump sent again
this says 751 a.m. Pacific time 10:51
a.m. Eastern Time 21 minutes into his
briefing my daughter Ivanka has been
treated so unfairly by Nordstrom's she
is a great person always pushing me to
do the right thing terrible Trump is
referring to the decision that
Nordstrom's made to remove Ivanka
Trump's clothing line which Nordstrom
says was not because of a political
situation but just because it wasn't
performing well it wasn't making enough
sales for them to want to keep it this
is the president using his position of
influence to influence the business
decisions of a particular department
store as related to his daughter's
personal financial interests this is
also Pat evidence that Trump is acutely
aware of what's going on with his kids
business is something we were told by
Trump and his attorney he wasn't going
to be involved in or made aware of it
all clearly he's very much aware of
what's going on it seems like he's going
to make a habit out of going after
specific businesses I mean Nordstrom
stock kind of dropped a little bit when
he sent this tweet out but then it had a
4% gain during the duration of the day
is there any more blatant involvement
that Donald Trump could have in his kids
businesses than tweeting specifics about
store decisions to carry or not carry
his daughter's clothing line
Trump is sending the message as Pat is
alluding to here that if you refuse to
do business with Trump's family you're
going to be publicly attacked that's the
definition of abusing your position for
financial benefit comedian and press
secretary Sean Spicer commented on this
saying that Nordstrom dropping Ivanka
Trump's clothing line is a quote direct
attack on the president
that's another admission of how the
Trump family is still fully invested in
their business and how Donald Trump is
directly involved in that and some
people emailed me Pat say David isn't
this illegal legal that doesn't matter
anymore I don't even know the answer
because it just doesn't matter whether
it's legal but just to be thorough I did
look into it and it is probably illegal
there was a message that was tweeted by
the message about the Nordstrom Ivanka
thing was tweeted from Trump's personal
account and then retweeted by the
official POTUS Twitter account which is
the White House communications team
presidential Twitter account and norm
Eisen who was the chief ethics lawyer
for the Obama White House and is now
working with Cru he suggested that this
might give Nordstrom standing to sue
Donald Trump under unfair competition
laws specifically California state law
it you know as I've said before Trump
can violate the Constitution unless
someone actually acts on it it doesn't
really make a difference so while this
was probably illegal I don't expect to
see any repercussions well I don't think
so either because Nordstrom actually
benefited off of this as I said I mean a
four percent stock increase you know
they have every right to drop Ivanka
Trump's clothing line yeah clearly it
was a bad reflection on their company
and you know Trump said should stay out
of it again they're saying it wasn't a
political decision you see but the thing
is you'd be right even if they admitted
we just don't like Trump and we're
dropping it it still doesn't justify
presidential involvement to this level
with businesses they are claiming that
that it was just not selling a bottom
line this confirms to us that the entire
charade about Oh Trump's not even going
to know what's going on with his kids
businesses nevermind get involved in
them lie lie lie I guess you could call
it an alternative fact